y'a jamais arrêté de pleuvoir la journée
jamais ça peut pas oublier de même le
savoir était d'intimider s'arrête dans 5
minutes ne regarde même ça dure 5
minutes 10 minutes a duré toute la
journée c'est fou
ça monte à vue d'oeil je bosse bercy
s'arrête pas là ça va passer par dessus
bord
pour demeurer sens de ma question toutes
effondrées notamment de cuisine et elles
ont toutes une personne venait de
terminer des rénovations dans sa maison
lorsque le déluge à frapper la résidence
aux limites de la baie s'est rempli
d'eau jusqu'au deuxième étage une digue
en amont de la riviera a cédé inondant
tous ces souvenirs perte totale
c'est incroyable comme elle l'osce et
fort les bim
le bim centrale de la maison avait cédé
le plafond du fait des changements aux
le plafond a cédé
les 19 20 et 21 juillet 1996 plus de 250
mm depuis donc sur la côte-nord
charlevoix surtout sur le
saguenay-lac-saint-jean les rivières
gonfle à vue d'oeil
en portant des dizaines de routes et des
centaines de bâtiments
cette même rivière ha ha qui a ravagé la
maison de peur aux personnes cool à
quelques mètres de la résidence de kehl
et claveau il avait toujours dans le
même quartier juste à côté du dépanneur
qu'il opérait pendant le déluge
mais le paysage autour a été transformée
dans ses rues la lata 22 maisons qui ont
disparu mojo tel 23e à l'époque il avait
sorti cette statue du sacré coeur pour
conjurer le mauvais sort comme un
monticule de peu louche je laisse
d'aller la pile journal et je me
demandais quelle prière avait fait
l'apologie de lui parler comme un ami
dit toi tu fais ta job puis y'a plus
jamais y a plus jamais tomber tech et
nous sommes de contourner la statue
originale a toujours une place dans sa
maison et il en a même installé une plus
grande sur son terrain en souvenir de la
catastrophe à chicoutimi c'est le
quartier du bassin qui a été le plus
touché dans sa fameuse petite maison
blanche
l'homme d'affaires claude girard
possédait deux immeubles dans le secteur
ils ont été détruits après le déluge
il raconte que son père a été le plus
marqué par les événements c'était comme
un lion le plus qu'on aurait tiré de son
royaume l'un fait beaucoup de propriétés
ou dans nos bassins mon père et ben il
connut puis lui donc j'ai vu mon père
germont c'est moi passent un banc de
parc
même si le quartier de son enfance a été
dévasté claude girard est l'un des rares
à avoir réussi à passer à autre chose
rapidement
j'étais allé m'acheter un paquet de
cigarettes une caisse de 12 g bull à 12
puis j'ai fumé le paquet sainté monde et
foule main la mer je suivais gamal la
tayaba pressostat carré
la page a été plus longue à tourner pour
les élus qui ont traversé la crise
l'ex ministre françoise gauthier et
mairesse de laterrière lorsque les
éléments se sont déchaînés
je me disais c'est pas le temps de les
saler mes émotions même si j'en avais
beaucoup vous allez gens comptent sur
moi alors fort que demeure fois depuis
qu'on prenne des décisions
elle a dû mettre en branle les mesures
d'urgence pour venir en aide aux deux
mille sinistrés de la petite
municipalité la chance que j'ai eue il
avait déconseillé musicaux étaient très
solidaires avec moi ya pas eu de game
politique personne assez de faire des
gains politiques avec ce dossier là au
contraire on notre travail et pour la
population
25 ans plus tard françoise gauthier
plusieurs autres ont tiré des leçons de
cet événement exceptionnel même si j'y
croyais beaucoup avant j'ai eu la
démonstration la cac 40 quand on est
travaille ensemble on peut passer à
travers des pires crises qui date tout
ce que sait qu'on doit véhicule chez
coach ware et chocolat ya pu rien à foot
vallon
c'est vraiment juste le centre si mal de
dettes ensemble de foncer ensemble pour
traverser l'épreuve pearl personnel est
maintenant convaincu que le déluge a eu
un impact positif dans sa vie après le
drame c'est elle qui a mené le recours
collectif contre la papetière abitibi
consolidated mes confrères de travail
mené par l'arête d'autres forces et
c'est pas bon pour toi soit 30 malades
puis moi - ça me faisait non moins faux
cache pas il faut que je kiffe au cash
back sketch autres les démarches
judiciaires l'ont forcé à sortir de sa
coquille et à s'impliquer
la compagnie a finalement dû verser 14
millions $ en dommages et intérêts à
quelque 350 sinistrés ça a été une
expérience qui a été très enrichissante
règle ça
ça m'a vraiment fait grandir ça m'a
vraiment fait sortir deux de trauma que
j'avais eu peut-être que ça aurait pas
tourner de la même façon si j'avais pas
vécu les innovations et si j'aime
n'était pas impliqué comme requérant
depuis le déluge pearl personnes
refusent de s'enraciner bien longtemps
elle a déménagé 29 fois quatre provinces
différentes
elle a posé ses quelques boîtes à québec
il y a un an pour l'instant jamais
[Musique]